А, не попала!
Буду перебивати.
— Ну, дивіться...
— А ну, може той...
— ...ну, це по великому блату!
— Хах!
— Ви можете то перебити.
— Ні, вже все, старію.
Вже все? Бачите,
два роки тому ще працювало.
Старе є старе.
Зараза!
Я не можу по палці потрапити.
[вдвох сміються]
— О!
— Оу! Є!
Кам'он, чемпіони.
Село розташоване отак на пагорбі.
І з трьох боків села тече річка Сула,
причому в більшій частині вона
розходиться в плавні біля нас.
Тут своя погода,
якась своя атмосфера,
відчувається, ніби ми
окремо від усього світу,
ніби така відокремлена спільнота.
Більшість людей, які тут живуть,
живуть тут століттями.
Тобто тут є чотири чи п'ять
козацьких прізвищ.
Вони всі так чи інакше
пов'язані кровними узами.
І це, фактично, все одна
велика родина.
Тут люди з самого початку розуміли,
що до них не прийдуть
і не зроблять [за них],
що це треба брати і робити самим.
І це, фактично, така стара,
закрита спільнота,
яку почали розбавляти
всілякі заїжджі.
В якийсь момент ми дивним чином
таки домовились про те,
що ми хочемо переїхати в село.
Нам в місті просто стало тісно й душно.
Ну, це Борщага,
суворий край.
Було важко, і подруга
покликала до себе в село.
Людина, яка нам його показувала,
нас одразу вивезла в ту частину села
[показує напрямок].
І там каже: «Отут були скіфські кургани,
а отут в нас схід сонця».
Ми так сіли на цьому горбочку,
посиділи, комарів було тьма.
І я кажу: «Ні, ну, це все,
на цьому вибір закінчився».
Була ідея, може треба
повибирати села.
Але це було перше,
в яке ми приїхали вибирати,
і в ньому ж і лишилися.
Ще одні диваки приїхали.
Людям...
Ну, моє сприйняття було принаймні,
що вони не розуміли, якого біса.
«Ти вдома мав...»
Вони так і питалися:
«У тебе дома унітаз був, ванна,
магазини всі під боком, робота, асфальт.
Ні корови, ні комарів.
Чого тебе сюди принесло?».
Пояснювати людині, що «вау, тут природа!»?
«Ну і що з того, що природа?»
Для них природа це те,
з чим вони жили.
Вони не розуміли, чому ми відмовилися
від «комфорту, достатку».
І переїхали в село мух годувати.
Мої батьки були трохи засмучені.
Мене колись в дитинстві
мама тим лякала,
що «не будеш вчитися —
будеш бикам хвости крутити».
Ну мої теж спочатку робили,
батько особливо, трагедію:
«Боже, вивчилася в найкращих
навчальних закладах!».
Ну спершу його трохи роздратувало,
що я в Могилянку на філософію пішла.
Каже: «Ото будеш, як Сковорода:
боса і з торбою».
І хто знав, що я переселюся
у край Сковороди?
І діти будуть босі чисто,
а я от в кроксах.
Торби, правда, ще не нажила.
Це трошки пізніше напевно
прийде, з досвідом. [сміються]
Ми зрозуміли, що від влади чекати грошей
чи якоїсь підтримки, це дохлий номер.
І подумали: «Ок'ей, чим ми можемо бути корисні,
раз ми такі освічені, англомовні тощо?»
Ми можемо заводити додаткові гроші
в село на якісь менші проєкти.
Ми тоді хотіли зробити ремонт клуба.
Так, це було перше.
Була можливість брати гранти,
зареєстрували, власне, під це ГО.
І це в такий спосіб визначило старт проєкту,
що він буде орієнтований на те,
щоб люди більше знали одне одного.
Наше ГО «Живе село» підписало меморандум
з Лохвицькою міською радою на два роки про те,
що ми можемо використовувати це
приміщення для облаштування музею,
що би це не значило.
Оця споруда — це Христанівська школа.
Вона — пам'ятка архітектури завдяки зусиллям
організації «Школи Лохвицького земства».
Зберігся двоскатний дах.
Оці шестикутні вікна-двері.
Музей історій Христанівки — це був
з самого початку проєкт не про те,
щоб зробити кімнату,
в якій будуть глечики.
Це з самого початку була ідея про те,
щоб позбирати прості історії людей.
І тому ми вибрали таким слоганом
для старту музею слова:
«Заговори, і я тебе побачу».
Це про те, що часто люди просто на рівні
фотографії приїжджають в село.
І там: киця, курочка, бабуська.
Якось лишають на рівні зображень,
але не дають людям сказати сло́ва.
Селу треба було повернути
відчуття того, що воно живе,
що воно буде якось розвиватися,
що в нього є якісь перспективи.
Ми з нашими ресурсами
не можемо працевлаштувати всіх,
видати більші пенсії абощо.
Ми робили те, що могли робити,
і ми робили акцент на спільноту,
про те, що вони дуже гарно
одне одного підтримують.
У них є ці навички співпраці і взаємодії.
Ми хотіли це просто підсилити
і показати більш наочно.
Тому перше, що ви зустрічаєте
в нашому музеї,
це ось тут є така часова шкала.
І люди на День села могли підійти,
взяти картку.
Оранжеві — це чоловіки,
зелені — це жінки.
І вони могли як себе
помістити на цій шкалі,
так могли помістити і своїх бабів,
дідів — доки вони пам'ятають.
Чим більше ти відчуваєш приналежність
до місця чи спільноти, я собі так уявляю,
тим більше в тебе
за неї відповідальності.
І тим більше тобі хочеться
в неї інвестувати.
А якщо ти прийшов, як в гості, і кажеш:
«Та ні, я тут тільки 45 років живу, я тут ні до чого»,
тоді менше шансів, що людина
долучиться і буде робити.
Починався проєкт наш,
музей історій, з того,
що ми просили старі
сімейні фотографії.
З тим, щоб їх взяти, відсканувати
і повернути назад.
І тоді вже можна було їх,
власне, роздрукувати на А4.
Так, я їх обробляла, хоча
це непрофесійна обробка.
Але скільки ми могли,
стільки ми їх почистили і збільшили.
І стали зустрічатися в магазині,
і щоразу як приходили,
обговорювали дуже, хто є що.
Багато хто хотів, мовляв,
«а дай мені це фото, а дай мені те».
Оцю багато хто хотів, бо...
Оце теперішня наша мафія
христинівська така, «бабківська».
То це вона на цій фотографії,
ми так зробили на цей розворот.
І ми хотіли там втиснути максимум,
щоб вернути всю цінність,
всі наші найкращі задумки.
Ми намагалися втиснути в цей журнал.
І щоб вони могли почитати
історії одне одного.
Люди поприносили...
Васильківська школа віддала все, що вони
збирали щодо етнографічних якихось штук.
Якщо чесно, ми до кінця не дуже
знаємо, що з цим робити.
У нас тут є місцева спільнота у фейсбуку.
Я туди кожну річ окремо,
теж прономерували...
І там в коментарях: «А моя бабуся цей,
а тут мені аж запахло, а тут…»
Коротше, дуже багато
спогадів піднялося.
Я поробила скріншоти
цих всіх коментарів.
І подумала, що замість музейного
опису, таблиці такої експертної,
що ми точно знаємо, для чого воно,
ми хотіли більше живе обговорення.
Усі ходять по цих краєзнавчих музеях,
такі експерти, кажуть: «Так, це прядка».
Кажу: «Ти цю нитку затягни і покажи,
як ця нитка робиться в цій прядці».
Мені подобається ця ідея.
Це, принаймні, зрозуміло,
що робити з тими предметами.
Але хочеться реально
продіти цю нитку.
Хочеться реально, щоб цей горщик
люди могли попіднімати.
Тобто такий тактильний досвід прожити.
Трішки вернути реально...
Якщо люди повертаються в дитинство,
потрапляючи в село,
давайте їм допоможемо.
Давайте вони пограють в ігри,
почіпають ці предмети, помісять глину.
Ну я не знаю...
Якась у вас довга вона!
Бери коротшу.
Ого, вийшло!
— Майже. Тепер ви пасете чи ні?
— По подвійному вийшло.
Вийшло!
— Ой, баба на старість ще й в «цурки» пограє!
— А я тут немов сторожую.
Ми з бабцями говорили
про їхню молодість і дитинство.
Вони ж пригадали старі ігри,
в які вони грали.
І одна з них була «цурки-палки».
Ця гра існує по всій Україні.
А потім почали питати,
і виявилося,
що Східна Європа також
грала в «цурки-палки».
Просто воно трішки
по-різному називалося.
Тому що ти ж молоденька.
Я й не бачу, де й ямка.
Гуляти раденька. А може і потрапили б,
якби я не сторожувала?
[сміється]
Та тут вже не махай,
бо я вже потрапила.
Отак вдарити,
а тоді отак...
— О, бачите!
— А тоді цілься, щоб потрапити в ямку.
І оце в нас в дитинстві така була гра.
Заміж вийшла,
вже в «цурки» не грали,
вже в «носовичка» грали підкладного.
І пляшку повертали, щоб цілуватися.
[сміються]
— Ми привезли з собою місто.
— Так.
Ми пробували різко змінювати місцевих.
Підлаштовувати, щоб вони
в нашому часі [були].
Мовляв, я ж сказав,
тайм-менеджмент!
От...
А тут так не працює,
тут по-іншому.
І ми трошки спустили пару.
Ми стараємося жити,
підлаштовуватися, перенавчатися.
Тобто село — це сезонне життя.
Ти живеш розмірено,
від сезону до сезону.
Тут нема того поквапу,
як в місті.
Я став спокійніший, повільніший,
я заповільнився.
Я навчився тут вчитися робити роботи,
які я ніколи не робив, наприклад,
не вмів, і не боятися цього.
Але ми переїхали в червні.
І для місцевих це означало:
«О, Боже, вони не встигли посадити грядку!»
І в нас стільки овочів,
як того року, не було ніколи.
Тому що від кабачків почалося,
і [несли нам] все відрами, відрами, відрами.
Тобто ми не встигали обробляти.
Нам приносили курят, гусят.
— Так.
— Бо куди ж в селі без цього?
Ну тобто я б сказала, що гарно...
Ну диваки диваками,
але при цьому я відчула
це тепло й хорошу увагу.
— Там нам навіть консервації понаносили.
— Консервації понаносили, так.
[розмовляють між собою]
Це був магазин.
І він закрився на якийсь другий чи
третій рік, як ми сюди переїхали.
Ну, він збитковий.
І нам просто стало
шкода місцевих людей,
які хліб чекали на вулиці
взимку і влітку.
Оце мерзли бабусі.
Була можливість, Оксанин брат допоміг,
ми це приміщення викупили.
Довели в міру своїх можливостей до ладу.
Спершу тут був просто магазин.
Потім з'явилася трошки бібліотека,
вона частину прилавків займала.
Потім сюди приїхав «Банк речей».
Це нам люди присилають речі,
які вони вже не носять.
У хорошому стані.
Частину забирають місцеві люди.
Також приїжджають з інших сіл,
тобто багатодітні, малозабезпечені.
І все, що залишається,
ми віддаємо на церкву.
Але вершиною проєкту
«Банк речей» був момент,
коли одна з односельчанок
принесла свої речі.
Каже: «Я вже повніша, вони на мене
не налазять, але ж ловкі, нашим підійдуть».
І вона реально віддала в «Банк речей».
Думаю, що це класно,
що не тільки нам повинні присилати
і нас мають підтримувати,
але й ми самі нівроку, у мене
ось є речі, які я можу звільнити.
Ми ще давно думали перед цим,
куди розмістити бібліотеку.
І ми просто половину приміщення
віддали під бібліотеку.
Бо теж така ідея була,
що навмисно в бібліотеку
навряд чи би хтось ходив.
А магазин — це місце,
куди всі так чи інакше сходяться.
Ми робили читання в бібліотеці.
Бо мої люблять, я люблю.
І хотілося поділитися цією любов'ю
і зробити це класним досвідом.
— Ми читали на вулиці.
— І на вулиці, і в школі, і біля школи.
Ми шукали, де...
І в полях читали.
Робили якісь регулярні події,
щоб воно якось пішло.
Люблять у нас брати от,
я здивувався,
але в мене перечитали
всього Марка Вовчка.
Панас Мирний. Його одна людина
вже по третьому колу перечитує.
Тут одна дівчинка, просто
не було інтересу в неї до читання.
Уже клас другий чи третій був.
І щось вона взяла одну з книжок.
І їй так сподобалося, що вона
почала дуже багато читати.
Вичитала всю бібліотеку.
І мама потім на радощах
таку ж книжку купила додому.
Просто в пам'ять про це.
Запрошуємо або волонтерів,
або друзів.
Тому що теж треба, час від часу, не тільки
варитися в своєму соку, але й назовні.
Ми зрозуміли, що індивідуальних гостей дуже
важко приймати, дуже важко обслуговувати.
Оптимальніше було б приймати групи.
І ми б хотіли розвивати це як ретрит-центр
[відновлювальний центр],
працювати на якесь психологічне
відновлення, розвиток, освіту.
Тобто класно, щоб цей музей був
не спорудою, де законсервоване...
А там мають бути простори
власне дискусійні, подієві.
Тут і природа.
Хочеш-не-хочеш,
ти все одно живеш,
тому що вона довкола тебе,
вона по тобі повзає, вона тебе їсть.
Ти нею дихаєш.
Тут вдень небо просто над головою,
бо в місті неба не видно, тому що будинки.
Особливо в Києві, де проспекти,
треба задерти [голову].
А вночі тут видно зірки.
До того, як приїхав сюди,
я бачив Молочний шлях востаннє
десь в глибокому дитинстві,
коли міста ще були темні.
А тут виходиш ввечері з собакою,
дивишся і бачиш Молочний Шлях.
Мене це дуже вразило.
Я просто забув, наскільки
в нас багато зірок навколо.
— Чумацький Шлях він називається.
— Ну Молочний, Чумацький.
[російською] «Молочний Шлях» —
це російською, це калька.
— Ну калька.
[сміються]
Вона зау́чка просто.
Хай щастить вам всюди,
хай усмішка не сходить з лиця!
Хай життя вам піснею буде,
а в тій пісні не буде кінця!
Здоров'я вам, щастя, любові, достатку!
Щоб долари й гривні водилися!
Хай щастить!
Скрізь і всюди!
Спасибі, що ви мене не забуваєте.